We train psychologists to think brilliantly, but no one really teaches us how to feel, not properly, not in our bodies. Today I'm joined again by Dr. Sunilad, consultant counselling psychologist, and we're talking about something most clinicians were never trained in, embodied practice. Because here's the uncomfortable truth. You can analyze anger, you can formulate trauma, you can intellectually understand stress, and still be completely disconnected from your own body. In this episode, we explore what happens when you stop trying to think your way out of discomfort and start learning the way to feel your way through it instead.
我们把心理学家培养成善于深度思考的人，但没有人真正教过我们如何去感受，不是恰当地感受，不是在身体层面去感受。今天，我再次邀请到咨询心理学家顾问苏尼拉德博士，我们要探讨的是大多数临床医生从未接受过培训的话题：具身实践。因为这里有一个令人不安的真相。你可以分析愤怒，你可以梳理创伤，你可以在理性上理解压力，但却可能完全与自己的身体失去连接。在这一集里，我们探讨了当你不再试图用理性摆脱不适，而是开始学习去感受并穿过不适时，会发生什么。
If you work in mental health, if you live in your own head, or if you're constantly on and don't know how to switch off, this conversation is for you. I hope you'll find it really helpful if you do. Please comment, like and subscribe for more. Hi, welcome along to the podcast. I am joined again today by the incredible Dr. Sanil Lad, who is a consultant counselling psychologist. Hi, Sanel. Hi, Mary Ann. Good to see you again.
如果你从事心理健康工作，如果你总是过度思虑，或者如果你总是处于紧绷状态却不知该如何放松，这场对话正是为你准备的。希望你能从中受益。如果你觉得有帮助，请评论、点赞并订阅以获取更多内容。嗨，欢迎来到本播客。今天我再次邀请到了杰出的咨询心理学家苏尼尔·拉德博士。嗨，苏尼尔。嗨，玛丽安。很高兴再次见到你。
Lovely to have you here. And today we are talking about a different topic. For anybody who might want to catch up on our previous episode, where we're talking about growing up in a different body, please do check that out. Could I ask you what embodied practice means to you? Yeah, so I think that's really important. question. So I'm, so when was it back eight, nine years ago now, I trained as a yoga teacher. But before that, one of the things I started to recognise that being a psychologist very much got stuck in the head. And what embodied practice means to me is actually how do we start to feel,
很高兴你能来到这里。今天我们要讨论一个不同的主题。任何想回顾我们上一集关于在不同身体中成长的主题的朋友，请务必去看看那一集。我想问一下，具身实践对你意味着什么？是的，我认为这是一个非常重要的问题。所以，大概在八、九年前，我接受了瑜伽教练的培训。但在那之前，我开始意识到的一件事是，作为一名心理学家，我们的思维往往局限在头脑中。而具身实践对我来说，实际上意味着我们如何开始去感受，
not just in our head, but within our bodies, but started to link in that sense of felt experience, whether that is an emotion, but be able to move it through the body, for example, not just through thinking differently. So are we talking about, you know, when we're with a client, for example, when we notice a physical reaction to something they say, are we talking about that level of kind of connectedness and sharing our journey? Or are we more talking about our own embodied practice and a sense of ourselves in our body? Could you kind of talk to us about that?
不仅在头脑中感受，也在身体内感受，并开始将这种身体层面的体验联系起来，无论那是一种情绪，还是能够让它在身体中流动，比如，不只是通过改变思维方式来做到这一点。所以我们在谈论的是，比如说，当我们和来访者在一起时，当我们注意到他们所说的话引起了某种身体反应时，我们是在讨论那种连接感以及分享我们的旅程的层面吗？还是我们更多地在讨论我们自己的具身实践以及我们在身体中的自我意识？你能跟我们谈谈这个吗？
Yeah, that's a really good question, Marian. I often don't, you know, if we think from a psychology perspective, there's often, you know, feelings of transference, countertransference, We might feel something in our body, but we often go into this sense of interpretation. What I like about embodied practices, when we start to feel from the bottom up rather than the top down, it's that sense of, well, actually, how could I, if, for example, I'm feeling anger, rather than using a technique to switch it off or to say this anger is not real, actually an embodied practice might be about how do I use my breath, how do I use my body,
是的，这是一个很好的问题，玛丽安。我经常，你知道，如果我们从心理学的角度来思考，通常会有转移、反转移的感觉。我们可能会在身体里感觉到某些东西，但我们往往会陷入这种解释的感觉中。我喜欢具身实践的一点是，当我们开始自下而上而不是自上而下地去感受时，那种感觉是，好吧，实际上，如果我正在感到愤怒，比如，我如何才能做到——而不是使用某种技术来关闭它，或者说这种愤怒不是真实的——事实上，具身实践可能关乎我如何使用我的呼吸，我如何使用我的身体，
how do I scream and shout, for example, in order to let it go, but without a sense of needing to hurt anyone? Yeah, okay, when I was working in youth prisons, my job was to kind of look at anger and young people, I would be so much better at that job now than I was in my mid-20s, mid-to-late-20s. as I'll say. And at the time, lots of advice around how to deal with anger was, you know, go and punch your pillow or go and kick something. And actually, even at the time, I'm not sure, more sure this is right. I'm not sure this is sitting right with me because that is showing that we need to be able to do something physical to almost kind of decompress this anger. And that I just don't think is functional. And sometimes that is, has been picked up in a
比如，我如何尖叫和呐喊，以便释放它，同时又不需要伤害任何人？是的，好的，当我曾在青年监狱工作时，我的工作是观察年轻人的愤怒，如果让我现在去做那份工作，我会比我二十多岁时做得好得多。而且当时，关于如何处理愤怒的很多建议都是，去打你的枕头或者去踢什么东西。事实上，即使在当时，我也不确定，我越来越觉得这可能不对。我觉得这不太对劲，因为这表明我们需要做一些体力活动来几乎是宣泄这种愤怒。我只是觉得这并不实用。有时这在
in a household as a learned strategy, as a copied strategy of watching grown-ups deal with conflict, watch grown-ups deal with anger. And actually, it's really interesting when we work clinically with people, is that often they think anger and violence are the same, and they're not. It's possible to be angry and write a strongly worded letter to ASDA. It doesn't always mean that you're going in
家庭中被作为一种习得的策略、一种通过观察成年人处理冲突和愤怒而模仿的策略被习得。事实上，当我们对人们进行临床工作时，非常有趣的一点是，他们经常认为愤怒和暴力是一回事，但它们其实不是。你可以感到愤怒，并给阿斯达写一封措辞强烈的信。这并不总是意味着你要冲进去
and you're smashing things up and, you know, scaring or intimidating people, does it? No, not at all. And I think there's something about actually, how do you really sit with what that anger might mean? And it's often, you know, what has it triggered off for? What does that mean, for example? And I guess, again, I work from a very much a CFT,
把东西砸个稀巴烂，然后去吓唬或恐吓别人，对吗？不，完全不是。我认为关键在于，你如何真正去体悟这种愤怒可能意味着什么。通常情况下，你知道，它触发了什么？例如，这意味着什么？我想，再次强调，我很大程度上是从接纳承诺疗法（CFT）、
a compassionate mind perspective, and thinking from an evolutionary perspective. So what is it about this experience that has set off that level of defence. Is it something that really needs to be there? But also, what have I learnt throughout my life, which means that this pattern keeps playing itself out, for example? Why does someone cutting me up really create that angry response?
慈悲心视角以及演化心理学的角度来进行工作的。那么，这种体验究竟是什么，引发了那种防御级别？它是那种真正需要存在的防御吗？而且，我在一生中学到了什么，导致这种模式不断重演？为什么有人别车会真正激起那种愤怒的反应？
Is it that actually I thought I was going to die, for example? Or is it just become, like you said, a learned behaviour where anyone, because it's about me as a person, how dare they do that type? of thing to me. So I think there's something about how I use my yoga practices to not only be aware, and I'm not just talking about the physical yoga, which we often see, but a lot more of the deeper yoga knowledge that I'm aware of that I've been studying over the last few years. That about get me a sense of, well, what does non-violence mean, for example?
是因为我当时觉得我要死了吗？还是说，就像你说的，它变成了一种习得的行为，觉得任何人——因为这关乎我作为一个人的尊严——怎么敢对我做出那种事。所以我想，我如何运用我的瑜伽实践，不仅是为了保持觉察——我指的不仅仅是我们常看到的身体瑜伽，而是我过去几年一直在学习的更深层次的瑜伽知识——来帮助我获得一种感觉，比如，非暴力究竟意味着什么？
Yeah, and I think it's only really probably my experiences with yoga and Pilates that get me to check in with my body fairly regularly. And I'm like, oh, Marianne, like drop those shoulders down. Like we don't want to be wearing noses earrings. And just the difference that that level of attunement to our body and kind of checking in mindfully in that moment can be transformational, can't it? Yeah, and I think that's a really important point to think about in terms of how we live our life. at the moment. We're often not checking into our bodies instead what we're doing. We're looking outside. We're checking our phones. We're checking even all those different gadgets, which might tell you your blood pressure is high, your pulse is high, you're not sleeping rather than really
是的，而且我想大概只有通过我练习瑜伽和普拉提的经历，才能让我相当定期地去觉察自己的身体。我会想：“哦，玛丽安，把肩膀放下去。我们可不想把耳环当项链戴。”这种对身体的调谐水平，以及在那一刻进行正念觉察的差异，真的可以带来颠覆性的改变，不是吗？是的，我认为这是一个非常重要的观点，值得我们思考我们目前的生活方式。我们往往没有去觉察身体，相反，我们在做的是：我们向外看。我们查看手机。我们甚至查看所有那些不同的设备，它们可能会告诉你你的血压高了、脉搏高了、你没有睡好，而不是真正地
asking yourself and developing the tools to actually understand, well, what is it that you actually are feeling in your body? How do you train yourself? How do you start to practice all those things that make you shine that spotlight into yourself. And I think, you know, the way that we live our lives now is very different to many hundreds, thousands of years ago, for example, when we were connecting to nature, walking around, doing all those things. No wonder, the NHS has got all sorts of problems with people with their backs and all of those kind of things. Because actually, in terms of how we've developed, actually, we're not necessarily practicing. those things. We're living lives which are quite sedentary, so we're not kind of looking after
去问自己，并培养能够真正理解以下问题的工具：你身体里实际感受到的到底是什么？你如何训练自己？你如何开始实践那些能把聚光灯照向自省的种种方法？我认为，我们现在的生活方式与几百、数千年前（例如我们与自然连接、四处走动、做所有这些事情的时候）有很大不同。难怪NHS（国民保健署）有各种各样关于人们背痛以及诸如此类的问题。因为实际上，就我们的进化方式而言，我们不一定在实践
our bodies in the same way. We're feeding ourselves all sorts of stuff which can be really unhelpful. You know, over the last couple of weeks, I've tried to have a bit of a detox off social media. It's quite interesting, you know, what kind of information that feeds our mind, especially at the moment with whatever's going on in the world. Actually, how that can also lead to that sense of fight and flight constantly coming on because we're getting angry by what we're seeing, but also what the algorithms are doing. They're not giving us hopeful messages all the time.
那些事情。我们过着相当久坐的生活，所以我们并没有以同样的方式照顾我们的身体。我们给自己灌输各种可能完全无益的东西。你知道，在过去的几周里，我试着对社交媒体进行了一点排毒。这挺有意思的，你知道，那种信息是如何喂养我们的头脑的，尤其是目前世界上正在发生各种事情的时候。实际上，这也会导致我们的战斗或逃跑反应不断被触发，因为我们对所看到的东西感到愤怒，同时也因为算法的作用。它们并不总是给我们传递充满希望的信息。
They're giving really kind of dark and dangerous things at times, or also lots of divisive messages that start to make us feel fearful or hatred towards other groups as well. Yeah, yeah, I totally agree. And I think anything that we, do that gets us to really think about our body in the moment can almost show us when we're using it not properly. So I've been weight training for about just over four years now and very accidental. That's the whole story how that happened. But I now, when I'm stacking
它们有时会传递非常黑暗和危险的东西，或者传递许多分裂性的消息，开始让我们对其他群体感到恐惧或憎恨。是的，是的，我完全同意。我认为我们所做的任何能够让我们在当下真正思考身体的事情，几乎都可以向我们展示我们什么时候没有正确地使用它。所以我大约在四年多前开始进行力量训练，这完全是个意外。那是关于它是如何发生的整个故事。但现在，当我
my dishwasher, will get myself into a position where I can do flat back to do it. And that actually is going to be much more protective of my back than kind of hunching over and kind of just not using my body in a way that's going to prevent injury. And even the way I stand when I'm boiling the kettle, I'm just more purposeful about the way that I use my weight distribution. Are there any other ways that we can kind of start to become more embodied? I really like the particular word that you're focused on, start. Because, you know, often people talk about, oh, well, I can't do yoga because I'm not
装洗碗机时，我会调整到一个能够保持背部平直的姿势去完成。这实际上对我的背部有更好的保护作用，而不是弯腰驼背，或者以一种无法防止受伤的方式使用我的身体。甚至当我烧水时我站立的方式，我对体重分布的方式也更有目的性。还有什么其他方法可以让我们开始变得更加具身化吗？我非常喜欢你所强调的那个词：“开始”。因为，你知道，人们经常会说：“哦，我练不了瑜伽，因为我不
flexible because I've seen this kind of picture of mainly it's women, but women doing bendy positions in a way. And yoga has now become that in itself. I think what I'd say is that actually what we need to learn to do is actually what is the relationship we need to have with our body. Again, focusing on the whole kind of compassionate mind three systems, trying to think, think about the intention that you go to a class with in order to develop that relationship with the body, trying to avoid getting into that blue system, the drive system, the achievement system. We often, you know, even do different practices to achieve something. So how can we look at doing practices just to develop a relationship? How do we develop that relationship to
灵活，因为我看到过这种图片——主要是女性——以某种方式做出弯曲的姿势。”瑜伽现在本身就变成了那样。我想说的是，实际上我们需要学习去做的是：我们需要与我们的身体建立什么样的关系。再次聚焦于慈悲心系统的三个系统，试着去思考你带着什么意图去参加一个课程，以便与身体建立那种关系，试着避免陷入那个蓝色系统、驱动系统、成就系统中。我们常常，你知道，甚至为了取得某种成就而去进行不同的实践。那么，我们如何看待仅仅为了发展关系而进行的实践？我们如何发展与
our body and be just really curious. How can we be playful? So if, for example, you do decide to have, you know, you decide to load your dishwasher. What if you moved in a certain way, in a different way? What if, for example, you know, one of the experiments I often do is, you know, if you clasp your hands together, what does that feel like? Now what I'd like you to do is change whatever the thumb, so if your left thumb was over your right thumb, moving it. Now, just kind of sensing and feeling that in the body, it might feel really weird because what you've just done is that you've just created this new pattern in your brain. And I think we get used to how our brains have been conditioned in a way.
身体的关系，并保持真正的好奇心？我们如何保持顽皮和游戏的心态？所以，如果你决定这样做，比如说，你决定去装洗碗机。如果你以某种特定的、不同的方式移动呢？如果，比如说，我经常做的实验之一是：如果你把双手十指紧扣，那感觉是什么样的？现在我想让你做的是，改变哪根大拇指在上——如果你的左大拇指在右大拇指上面，现在把它换过来。现在，去感知和感受身体里的这种感觉，这可能会感觉非常奇怪，因为你刚刚做的事情是在大脑中创造了一个新的模式。我想我们已经习惯了我们的大脑被训练成的那种方式。
And we just want that all the time because it feels comfortable, whereas we drew something new and it's like, oh, that doesn't feel nice. but the more you keep practicing it in that way, actually you'll just become accustomed to it. So the same way, how do we start? How do we start to develop that small relationship to our body? Be really curious and get a sense of, actually, if I've got tightness, if I've got inflexibility,
我们一直想要那种感觉，因为它让人感到舒适，而当我们尝试做一些新的事情时，就会觉得：“哦，这感觉不好。”但你越是以这种方式不断练习，实际上你就会习惯它。同样地，我们如何开始？我们如何开始发展与身体的小小关系？保持真正的好奇心，去体会：实际上，如果我有紧绷感，如果我不够灵活，
how can I be curious about it rather than shot myself off from it or just avoid doing it? Yeah, I think it's that idea when I've been doing strength training or even yoga for that matter. You've almost got to be able to tune into the day, different sensations your body can give you. So it can give you a little rumble, like, oh, don't carry on that because that hurts.
我该如何对它保持好奇，而不是将自己封闭起来或者干脆逃避它？是的，我想这种想法在我进行力量训练甚至瑜伽时都有出现。你几乎必须能够调谐到当下的状态，去感受身体带给你的各种不同感觉。所以它可能会给你一个小小的提醒，比如：“哦，别再继续那个动作了，因为那会疼。”
But you know, when it's sweet pain, when it's kind of ligaments and tendons stretching, maybe we can tolerate that for a little bit longer. Obviously, if it's a searing, stabbing pain, then we should stop that. But we can tolerate some uncomfortableness. And that might be an essential part of growing. So I think, you know, one of the things I often focus on is how do we be more comfortable about being uncomfortable?
但你知道，当它是“甜蜜的痛”时，当它是韧带和肌腱在拉伸时，也许我们可以多忍耐一会儿。当然，如果是剧烈的、刺痛的疼痛，我们就应该停下来。但我们可以忍受一些不适。这可能是成长的一个必不可少的部分。所以我想，我经常关注的事情之一就是：我们如何才能对“感到不适”感到更加自在？
You know, I think obviously growing up, life is uncomfortable. And I think what we've got to learn is how do we learn to sit with that in a better way? I think we're we've got loads of resources available towards now, which means that people want the easiest option, the quickest hack. And again, we're fed all this information through social media and stuff. We want the quick, easy answer in a way. But actually, sometimes for our growth, you know, I look back now. And even in my yoga practice, in my physical practices, I look back now.
你知道，我认为成长过程中，生活显然是不舒适的。我认为我们必须学会的是如何学会以更好的方式与这种不舒适共处。我觉得我们现在手头有大量资源，这意味着人们想要最简单的选择、最快捷的捷径。同样，我们通过社交媒体等渠道被灌输了所有这些信息。某种程度上，我们想要快速、简单的答案。但实际上，有时为了我们的成长，你知道，我如今回看过去。甚至在我的瑜伽实践中，在我的身体实践中，我回看过去，
And there are things that I couldn't ever do when I started where I can now. But that's taken years, but we're often on the mindset. Actually, in three classes, I want to get that done. You know, after this prescription, I want, you. know, it needs to be sorted, but that's not always possible. So I think it's really important we think about what needs to take a bit of time. How do we rewire our brain? But that takes a bit of time and effort as well.
有些事情我刚开始时绝对做不到，而现在我可以了。但这需要花费数年时间，但我们往往抱有一种心态：实际上，我希望通过三节课就搞定这一切。你知道，吃完这个处方药之后，你，你知道，问题就需要解决，但这并不总是可能的。所以我觉得，思考什么需要花一点时间是非常重要的。我们如何重新连接我们的大脑？但这同样需要一些时间和努力。
And I'm thinking about the embodied stuff as a way of buffering our stress as well. So I'm aware that I often will go to a Sunday lunchtime, if my kids aren't playing football, that is. a Sunday lunchtime yoga class. And it's a really nice, slow pace. So it is challenging at parts, but it's not, it's probably not the kind of class I might go to on a Saturday morning or on a Wednesday evening, like where I might want something a bit more stretchy. But it's about honouring that actually this is a really nice wind down to the week.
我把具身化的东西看作是一种缓冲压力的途径。所以我意识到，如果我的孩子们不踢足球的话，我经常会在周日午餐时间去上周日午餐时间的瑜伽课。那是一个非常好的、缓慢的节奏。所以它在某些部分具有挑战性，但它可能不是那种我会在周六早上或周三晚上去上的课，因为在那些时候我可能想要一些伸展更多一点的课程。但关键在于尊重这样一个事实：这真的是一周下来很好的放松方式。
It's a really nice chance to check in with my body. and to honour it and to know that in giving it that hour to rest, to recharge, to gently stretch, to feel strength and power and mastery, that that might well serve me incredibly well in all areas of my life. Yeah, and I think it's really important for us to kind of recognise, well, what are those strategies that we use? sometimes that can be helpful in the short term, but actually in the long term, there might not be very helpful. So I think as you were talking,
这是一个很好的机会，可以用来审视我的身体，尊重它，并且知道通过给它一个小时来休息、充电、温和地伸展、感受力量和掌控感，这可能在生活的方方面面都对我大有裨益。是的，我认为对我们来说，认识到我们使用的策略是什么非常重要。有时这些策略在短期内可能是有帮助的，但在长期来看，它们可能并没有什么帮助。所以我想，正如你刚才所说，
it really made me think about actually when I first started, you know, working in prisons throughout my careers has felt difficult, you know, hearing some really difficult stories. And sometimes back in the past, one of the things that I would do, if I'd had a really tough day, you know, had some really awful things,
它真的让我想起，实际上当我刚开始在监狱工作时，贯穿我职业生涯的经历一直让人觉得很艰难，听到一些非常艰难的故事。有时在过去，我会做的一件事是，如果我度过了非常艰难的一天，你知道，听到了一些非常糟糕的事情，
I'd kind of give myself a glass of wine or two and that'd be a way to kind of try to decompress or, you know, I guess it might be a bit of chocolate and everyone's, you know, everyone's coping strategies will be different that they've developed over their lifetime whether it is food, internet, anything, anything that is kind of addictive in a way, that gives comfort.
我会给自己倒上一两杯葡萄酒，以此作为一种放松的方式，或者，我想也许是一块巧克力，每个人的，你知道，每个人在生活中发展出的应对策略各不相同，无论是食物、互联网，还是任何带有某种成瘾性、能带来安慰的东西。
And I think that's the thing we need to kind of recognise, well, our body is constantly seeking comfort. in a way. And I remember once one of the things that happened, I had a really tough day and I decided actually rather than have a glass of wine tonight, I'm going to get on my yoga mat. And I got on my yoga mat and actually, you know, just the story that I'd heard was kind of continuing to go through my head. And then I'd just put a random playlist on and suddenly this song just really kind of really touched me. And next thing I know, I'm just in floods of tears with just the level of suffering that I'd sat with with that client that day. And I think
我认为我们需要认识到这一点，那就是：我们的身体一直在寻求某种安慰。我记得有一次发生了一件事，我度过了艰难的一天，我决定今天晚上与其喝一杯葡萄酒，不如去练瑜伽。于是我上了瑜伽垫，实际上，你知道，我听到的故事一直在我的脑海里盘旋。然后我随便放了一个播放列表，突然这首歌真的，真的触动了我。接下来的事情就是，我泪流满面，为那天我陪伴那个来访者所经历的痛苦而痛哭。我想，
there is something about how do we learn to nourish our bodies in a way which we're not often taught, which doesn't feel real. So, you know, it might be going for a walk or again, you know, something where we can just start to slow down. I think we're living in such a fast-paced world that slowing down feels quite wrong. It's like, oh no, I've not got time to slow down. But I think we probably get more awareness, more understanding once we do slow down.
这里面有些东西关乎我们如何学会以一种我们通常未曾被教导的、不虚假的方式来滋养我们的身体。所以，这可能是去散步，或者同样地，做一些能让我们慢下来的事情。我认为我们生活在一个节奏如此之快的世界里，以至于慢下来感觉是一件相当错误的事。就像是：“哦，不，我没有时间慢下来。”但我认为，一旦我们慢下来，我们可能会获得更多的觉察、更多的理解。
And I think it's about how do we give ourselves permission to do that, really. Yeah, and I think it's always holding in mind the kind of theory from the Bessel van der Kolp, the body keeps the score. If you hadn't done that, how can we know that that wouldn't have shown up somewhere later in your body, you know, that it just would have kept that all in? And so it's allowing, I think for me, it's building ways for us to move our body kind of fully in different ways to see, to see what thoughts, feelings, bodily sensations, that conjures for us and knowing that if we are working in mental health,
我认为这实际上关乎我们如何给自己这样做的许可。是的，并且我认为这总是让我想起贝塞尔·范德科克（Bessel van der Kolk）的理论，即“身体会记住一切”（The Body Keeps the Score）。如果你没有那样做，我们怎么知道这些不会在以后以某种方式在你的身体里表现出来呢？你知道，它只会把所有这些都压抑在体内。所以，允许——对我来说，就是为我们建立各种方式，以不同的方式充分活动我们的身体，去看看——去看看这会为我们唤起什么样的想法、感受、身体感觉，并且知道如果我们从事心理健康工作，
being subjected to either harrowing things that we hear or scary things or really just emotive, sad things, yeah, that does take its toll and we need to honour ourselves as humans, you know. And often we can't tell people this stuff. This is the tricky thing about being in our job. You might be able to talk to it with someone in your team who it's relevant to, but not everybody, and your supervisor and anyone in the managerial chain. But you can't be talking to everybody and people in your friendship circle and family about this.
我们要么承受着听到的悲惨事情，要么承受着可怕的事情，或者仅仅是那些充满情绪的、悲伤的事情，是的，这确实会带来代价，我们需要作为人类来尊重我们自己，你知道的。而且通常我们不能把这些事情告诉别人。这就是从事我们这份工作的棘手之处。你或许可以和团队里与此相关的人谈谈，但不是所有人，你可以和你的监督者以及管理链条中的任何人谈谈。但你不能跟所有人谈论这些，也不能跟你的朋友圈和家人谈论这些。
And so often what might be, you know, your go-to strategy might be talking, that's kind of off limits. And so you're having to think, well, what else can I do? Yeah, and I think there's something about what embodiment has meant for me. I think we might sometimes get caught up in the thinking loop, needing to analyse it. But like you said, in terms of some of the work that Bessel van de Kolt says, actually our body can also process things as well.
所以通常情况下，你的首选策略可能是倾诉，而这在某种程度上是受限的。因此你不得不思考：我还能做些什么？是的，并且我认为具身化对我的意义体现在某些方面。有时我们可能会陷入思维的循环中，觉得需要去分析它。但正如你所说，就贝塞尔·范德科克的一些观点而言，实际上我们的身体也可以处理事情。
And that's why, you know, whether it is any kind of somatic movement that we do, whether it's singing or dancing or yoga or any kind of expression of the body, how do we start to allow that to allow the energy to move through our body in terms of that trapped sense, the fear, the pain, the anguish of what it is to be human. Do you think this is something people ought to be starting to bring to supervision? You know, the way they're using their bodies to help manage life and to manage their kind of work experiences as well. And if they should be, how might that look during a supervision session, especially if it's not something that your supervisor is previously raised with you? How could they begin to do that, Sarnel? So I guess I'd say get creative. and that could be, you know, starting a supervision session off with checking into the body.
这就是为什么，无论是我们做的任何形式的躯体运动，无论是唱歌、跳舞、瑜伽，还是身体的任何表达形式，我们如何开始允许这些运动穿过我们的身体，去转化那种被困住的感觉——恐惧、痛苦、作为人类的苦难。你认为这应该是人们开始带入督导中的内容吗？你知道，他们用身体来帮助管理生活以及管理工作经历的方式。如果他们应该这样做，这在督导会议期间会是什么样子，特别是如果这不是你的监督者以前向你提出过的事情？萨尼尔，他们该如何开始这样做呢？所以我想我会说：发挥创造力。
You know, how often do we start off dependent on your modality with, right, well, what's on your agenda for supervision? Actually, yes, you know, I try and just check in with my colleagues of, well, how are you? But it's often what have you done over the weekend. But actually, what if we did a bit of a check-in of how are you in your body right now? what does it feel like you know when you're talking about this case and this problem that you're talking about can we just check in because i'm recognizing you know this is bringing up lots of thoughts
这可能是，你知道，以对身体的觉察来开始一次督导会议。你知道，根据你的流派，我们多久会以“好吧，你今天督导的议程是什么”来开始？实际上，是的，你知道，我尽量只是和同事们核对一下“你最近怎么样”。但这通常是问你周末做了什么。但是，如果我们做一次核对：此刻你的身体感觉怎么样？
how's it making your body feel so maybe there is just some kind of quick prompts that you can do especially when there is a high level of difficulty or you know a really tricky sticky problem to try and bring the focus back to the body. Because sometimes especially a psychologist, we love a good analysis and a formulation of something. But I guess grabbing that, you know, one of the things that I love tried to bring into my thinking is yogic wisdom as well. And, you know, within yogic wisdom, you've got something called the Kosci, which is the
当你谈论这个案例和你正在谈论的这个棘手问题时，感觉是什么样的？我们能核对一下吗，因为我意识到，这引发了许多想法，
different levels. So you've got the body, the energetic body, the mind body. and the kind of bliss body and stuff. But, you know, how do we start to bring those different bodies into our thinking? Because it isn't just about the mind. Yeah, absolutely. And this, you know, anyone listening or watching this might be like, this whole body thing, this is so different than what I'm used to.
它让你的身体有什么感觉？所以也许有一些快速的提示可以使用，特别是当遇到高度困难，或者一个非常棘手的难题时，可以尝试把焦点拉回到身体上。因为有时，特别是作为心理学家，我们热爱优秀的分析和个案构念。但我想，抓住这一点——我试图带入我的思考中的东西之一也是瑜伽智慧。而且，在瑜伽智慧中，你有一些叫做“鞘”（Koshas）的东西，也就是
You know, my parents weren't physically connected to their bodies. You know, the people around me, people didn't really exercise. we've all been very sedentary. It might sound like it's so alien to where you are right now. How would you begin to just be curious and do something differently? So I think it's important to kind of like you said, start somewhere small. You know, if we, again, the reflection might be of not only the environment you were growing up in, but also what was your journey?
不同的层面。所以你有身体、能量体、心智体、超越体等等。但是，我们如何开始将这些不同的身体带入我们的思考中？因为这不仅仅关乎心智。是的，绝对是这样。而且，听到或看到这一点的任何人可能会觉得：“这个整套身体的东西，这跟我习惯的太不一样了。”
So is it? Again, we think, you know, growing up here in England, the vast majority of our school life, we are just sitting. We're taking in learning through sitting. I think things are changing a bit more, but actually just recognising, apart from those couple of hours a week that we'd have PE, we'd generally be sitting for long, you know, a lot of our learning comes through sitting. But we know, for example, how we've developed as human beings when we flourish is through
你知道，我的父母并没有与他们的身体产生身体上的连接。你知道，我周围的人，大家其实都不怎么锻炼，我们都过着非常久坐的生活。这听起来可能与你现在的状态格格不入。你将如何开始仅仅去保持好奇并做一些不同的事情呢？所以我觉得重要的是，就像你说的，从某个小地方开始。如果我们再次反思，这不仅关乎你成长的环境，也关乎你的经历是什么。
and learning through play, for example. So how do we firstly recognize that, but then how do we introduce that playful aspect to our day-to-day lives because we can become so serious in learning as well? So how do we get more playful in terms of learning that relationship with the body? And that could be, you know, that could be various things using the five senses, using other people and working towards that, Or even, for example, if you have got a general practice of exercise,
所以是吗？同样，我们认为，在英格兰长大的我们，学校生活的大部分时间都只是坐着。我们通过坐着来接受学习。我认为事情正在发生更多变化，但实际上只要认识到，除了每周那几个小时的体育课之外，我们基本上都在坐着，你知道，我们的大量学习都是通过坐着进行的。但我们知道，例如，人类作为生物是如何进化的，我们繁荣发展的方式是通过
I'm not necessarily talking about yoga, but even just going to the gym, how can you start to really focus on how does your body feel when you're doing that? Again, are you focusing on achievement when you're doing an exercise, or are you focusing on connection? So a couple of weeks ago, I actually got the privilege of teaching just, some, doing some yogic practice to help staff actually to be more aware of their bodies. You know, we were thinking about self-care and that relationship. And just to recognise actually how often we get stuck in the threat system,
通过玩耍来学习，例如。那么我们如何首先认识到这一点，然后如何在我们的日常生活中引入这种玩耍的方面，因为我们在学习中也会变得非常严肃？那么我们如何通过学习与身体的关系变得更有游戏精神呢？这可能是，你知道，这可以是各种各样的事情：运用五官，借助他人并朝着那个方向努力，或者甚至，例如，如果你有一般性的锻炼习惯，
even though we might be sitting, breathing, there will be tension. We might be having a thought about, oh gosh, this long list of things I've got to do. And just noticing actually, so when you're in that state of mind, where in your body do you feel that? If you were to direct your breath and just try to slow down your breath in that very physical way, what starts to shift in your awareness, for example. So that slowing down is extremely important. It really is. And I'm a gym member and what I really love is just going along to a different class that I might not have done before.
我指的不一定是瑜伽，甚至只是去健身房，你如何才能开始真正专注于当你这样做时你的身体感觉如何？同样，当你锻炼时，你关注的是成就，还是关注连接？所以几周前，我有幸去教导一些员工，做一些瑜伽练习，帮助他们更好地觉察自己的身体。你知道，我们在思考自我照顾和那种关系。并且只是去认识到实际上我们多久会陷入威胁系统一次，
or seeing how my body and how my mind reacts to that, and often I'll have this idea, oh, I can't do this, I don't get this, I don't understand it. But when we just begin to quiet that noise a little bit and allow ourselves to learn, to be beginners, to just experience and explore and see how that feels, we might just find that, oh, that was enjoyable. When I didn't expect myself to be this master of something
即使我们可能正坐着呼吸，也会存在紧张感。我们可能脑子里在想：“哦天哪，我有一长串事情要做。”只要注意到实际上：当你处于那种心态时，你在身体的哪个部位能感受到这一点？如果你引导呼吸，并试图以非常物理的方式减慢呼吸，你的觉察中会开始发生什么转变，例如。所以这种放慢速度极其重要。确实如此。我是个健身房会员，我真正喜欢的是去上一些我以前可能没有上过的不同课程，
I've never done before, maybe I'll do that again. Maybe that was good. Maybe it's, yeah, it's good to do things we've never done before because something good might come out of it. Yeah, and actually if we think again about kind of brain training and, you know, developing new and neural hormonal pathways within our brains and bodies, that's a brilliant opportunity to do it. This class I went to, it's becoming a regular, but it was like a rave. It was like a rave with martial arts and really, like,
或者观察我的身体和我的心智对此如何反应，通常我会有这种想法：“哦，我做不到这个，我不懂这个，我不理解它。”但当我们只是稍微安静一下那些噪音，允许自己去学习、去成为初学者、去单纯地体验和探索并看看感觉如何时，我们可能就会发现：“哦，这其实挺享受的。”当我没有期望自己成为某种大师时——
music and lots of a room full of people that already knew what they were doing and me but it was really fun and yeah I'm it's now making making it irregular and just going with a bit of that wildness but just feeling how my body feels and sometimes you know when the mind switches off a little bit and just goes on autopilot that's a wonderful thing yeah no it's absolutely beautiful and I guess we need to bring more of that into our day-to-day lives and and you know, practice that because I'm sure a lot of people would feel better for it. I think so. Thank you so much for our time. Where can our audience learn more about you and your work, Sunil? So I guess the best place is probably my LinkedIn profile. I've often just share
那些我从未做过的事情——也许我还会再去。也许这很好。也许，是的，做一些我们从未做过的事情是很好的，因为可能会从中产生一些美好的东西。是的，实际上如果我们再次思考大脑训练，以及在我们的头脑和身体中发展新的神经激素通路，这是一个绝佳的机会。我去上的这门课，它正成为一种常规，但它就像是一场锐舞派对。它就像是一场融合了武术的锐舞派对，伴随着动感的音乐，房间里坐满了已经知道自己在做什么的人，而我则是那个新手，但这真的很有趣，是的，我，它现在正成为我的一项常规活动，伴随着一点点那种狂野感，但只是去感受我的身体感觉如何。有时候，你知道，当心智稍微关闭并进入自动驾驶状态时，那是一件美妙的事情。
various thoughts on there, but also yeah, often put on links. I do also have a TED talk on embodiment of my own personal experience of yoga on YouTube as well. Great. I will make sure all those links are in the show notes and the description. Thank you again for your time and wishing you well with everything you do. Thanks, Marion. It's great talking to you. Likewise. What an absolute delight to speak with Dr. Sunil. Again, it was the same day that we recorded it on, but his words have really stayed with me. So it's been a couple of weeks since the episode and since I did this because we had half term in the middle. But yeah, it's really
是的，这绝对是美妙的，我想我们需要将更多这样的元素带入我们的日常生活中，并且（你知道）去练习它，因为我相信很多人会因此而感觉更好。我也这么认为。非常感谢你抽出时间。我们的观众在哪里可以更多地了解你和你的工作，苏尼尔？所以我想最好的地方可能是我的LinkedIn个人资料。我经常在上面分享各种想法，但同时也是的，经常发布链接。我在YouTube上还有一个关于具身化的TED演讲，分享了我个人练习瑜伽的经历。太棒了。我一定会把所有这些链接放在节目文稿和简介中。再次感谢你抽出时间，祝你一切顺利。谢谢，玛丽安。很高兴和你交谈。彼此彼此。
stayed with me and I would love to know whether it resonated with you as well. Please do let me know in the comments and I would love to know if you find this helpful and if you love this episode, you can share any of my reels to your Instagram stories or you can reshare them on TikTok. That would be so gratefully received. Please do tag me in because I love knowing when this content with you. If you'd like to be part of the inner work, you can consider joining the backstage crew, which you can do either via Captivate, Spotify or YouTube, where you get exclusive members-only episodes, and they are called the Inner Work Now. So they're kind of companion episodes, but with new insights, thoughts and reflections from me. And yeah, they've got their very own
能与苏尼尔博士交谈绝对是一大快事。再次说明，我们在录制这一集时是同一天，但他的话真的深深印在了我的脑海里。所以距离这期节目播出以及我录制它已经过去几周了，因为中间我们放了期中假。但是，是的，它真的深深触动了我，我很想知道这是否也引起了你的共鸣。请务必在评论中告诉我，我很想知道你是否觉得这有帮助。如果你喜欢这期节目，你可以将我的任何短视频分享到你的Instagram快拍中，或者你可以在TikTok上重新分享它们。我会非常感激。请务必标记我，因为我喜欢知道这些内容是否与你产生了共鸣。如果你想参与内功修炼（inner work），你可以考虑加入后台船员（backstage crew），你可以通过Captivate、Spotify或YouTube加入，在那里你可以获得独家的仅限会员的节目，它们被称为“现在开始内功修炼”（The Inner Work Now）。所以它们有点像伴随性质的节目，但包含了来自我的全新见解、想法和反思。而且，是的，它们每周都有自己的主题。所以非常值得在Apple上参与免费的三天试用。然后如果你喜欢的话，你知道，你可能会想留下来。
theme each week. So it's very much worth diving in for the free three-day trial on Apple. And then if you like it, you know, you might want to stick around. So there's details in the show notes and in the description. And if you're an aspiring psychologist, I think you will love the aspiring psychologist membership, which you can join from just £30 a month with no minimum term. Head to wwwspiring hyphen psychologist.co.com. Then let this be your guide With this podcast, that's your side You'll be on your way to being qualified.
因此详细信息在节目文稿和简介中。如果你是一个有志成为心理学家的人，我想你会喜欢“有志心理学家会员计划”（aspiring psychologist membership），你只需每月30镑即可加入，没有最低期限要求。前往 www.aspiringpsychologist.co.uk。那么，就让这成为你的指南，有了这个播客在你的身侧，你将走上获得资格的道路。
It's the aspiring psychologist podcast With Dr. Marianne Trent There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
这就是有志心理学家播客，我是玛丽安·特伦特博士。本集暂无评论。点击转写文本中的任意句子即可发表评论。